You saw him yesterday in Pennsylvania where they, you know,
they managed to let them out of the basement basically.
So they could cut an ad to make it look like he's actually out there. You know,
it's all from the same shot, but you know,
Joe Biden was out of his basement miraculously for a few minutes,
but he forgets where he is. He forgets his wife from his sister.
He forgets the office. He's running for he's, he's looking at notes.
You see him. I mean, he literally read the subtext of the teleprompter stuff.
It looks like he's trying to give an organic interview when he's reading the
bullet points on a teleprompter because he can't remember them.
And now you compare that with, okay, two brain aneurysms.
It's probably an issue, nothing to see here, folks. I mean,
the cause and effect is so flavored and it, it would be sad, Dave,
if it wasn't so scary for our country.
So I read about him.
This morning and you just laid out a lot of the arguments that you made.
And when I was, when I was looking at it, I was thinking, you know, the,
the alternate title basically for this book could have been double standards,
right? Cause that's really what you're,
that's really what you're saying in this book that if my family did these
things, this is how the media would have portrayed it.
If my dad had made these decisions, this is what would happen.
And if I had gotten the benefits that say Hunter Biden had gotten,
this is how the media would have dealt it. I I've said a lot of people as,
as I've gotten more comfortable, let's say with your dad,
a lot of people will say to me, well, I don't get it, Dave, how could you,
how could you support Trump? How, how is he,
how come you don't think he's the devil, all of that kind of stuff.
And what I always say is, well,
he understood the media more than anything else that it
wasn't just, it wasn't just Republicans versus Democrats.
It was Republicans versus Democrats. Plus the media. That,
that to me seems to be a huge thrust of what this book is. Is it,
does it all boil down to the double standards thing for you?
Yeah, I mean, yes. And even, and more right. I mean,
cause it's not just a double standard, it's just flagrant mistakes. I mean,
if you're just looking at what's going on today, that, you know,
there was another fake report, you know, Donald Trump suffered, uh,
mini strokes, you know, now, and he had to be treated at Walter Reed.
Now the doctors at Walter Reed said, this is nonsense. It's untrue,
but the media won't even talk about Joe Biden.
Who's literally had two brain surgeries for literally
brain aneurysms. He had explosions in his brain. Now,
if you ask a doctor about that,
what are the chances that you could be a hundred percent normal after one re you
know, brain surgery that, you know, after an aneurysm, they'd say very little,
how about to almost impossible to be normal.
Now you take that with Joe Biden's daily, daily.
You saw him yesterday in Pennsylvania where they, you know,
they managed to let them out of the basement basically.
So they could cut an ad to make it look like he's actually out there. You know,
it's all from the same shot. But you know,
Joe Biden was out of his basement miraculously for a few minutes,
but he forgets where he is. He forgets his wife from his sister.
He forgets the office. He's running for he's, he's looking at notes.
You see him. I mean, he literally read the subtext of the teleprompter stuff.
It looks like he's trying to give an organic interview when he's reading the
bullet points on a teleprompter, because he can't remember them.
And now you compare that with, okay, two brain aneurysms.
It's probably an issue, nothing to see here, folks. I mean,
the cause and effect is so flagrant and it, it would be sad, Dave,
if it wasn't so scary for our country, you know,
Joe Biden is basically he's camouflage for the far left. They can try it.
The media will spend billions trying to sell him to middle America.
It's moderate Joe, moderate Joe. But you know,
you're not a moderate with Kamala as your VP. You're not a moderate with Bedo.
Hell yeah. I'll take your AR 15 O'Rourke as your guns are.
You're sure as heck not a moderate with the Bernie Sanders joint unity platform,
which is like a con combination of like the new age communist manifesto with the
green new deal blended into one. And again, the media won't talk about that.
So when you talk about, you know, double standard,
it's not even that because the playing field is so uneven with a mainstream
media. That's what, 96% negative against Donald Trump. I mean,
that's a lot of ground to overcome.
They won't talk about the good things you saw while you may have been off the
grid when this happened, but they got a peace deal done in the middle East.
I mean,
this is the Holy grail of geopolitical politics hasn't been done in a quarter of
a century.
They spent more time last week fact checking my three-year-old nephew.
If in fact he did build a Lego white house for my father.
Now there's a picture of it,
but they spend more time talking about that because Ivanka mentioned in her
speech attacking a three-year-old now, I mean, you know, Nick, Sandeman,
that's 60. They destroyed him. I figured, okay,
they wouldn't go much lower than that,
but now they're going to a three-year-old to attack him.
But the average American has no idea.
We signed a peace deal in the middle East and you know,
that's the insanity we're up against. So that's why this book,
it's not just for, you know,
people on the right it's for people in the middle who are undecided,
because if you're undecided and you're sort of going 50 50, either way,
imagine you actually knew about Joe Biden and his policies.
Imagine you actually heard about the Trump administration successes,
neither of which you've been made aware of.
That's what this book is it's designed to inform. And again,
it's more for the people in the middle that aren't sure than it is anything else
because someone had to step up and do it.
So in the, in the chapter about the Biden health stuff,
where you talk about the brain aneurysms and everything else,
and you refer to Obama's doctor and a bunch of other medical professionals in
it,
and you actually go out of your way to make a point that you're not trying to
mock the guy and you, and you have sympathy for this kind of stuff. Like you're,
you're not being a Dick about it. You really not. Yeah. Um,
one thing that you sort of hint at is basically, and,
and you sort of implied this already,
that he's just kind of a puppet for something. What,
what do you really think that thing is like, is it,
is it the party apparatus,
like who really is in charge of the DNC at this point?
Well, I think it's the radical left. I mean,
you saw that you saw that if you watch the DNC,
I don't know if you came out of hiding it from that one. If you didn't catch it,
it'll save you a lot of grief. Because if you watch that, you know,
you'd think that America was the most oppressive regime ever created in the
world. And that it's a terrible place. And you, again, I watched for five days,
not one person mentioned the looting, the writing, the violence going,
not one at the DNC, they had a week instead, they painted this picture of,
you know, America is a terrible place. If you like anything about it,
you're a terrible human being. And you know,
that's the thing I wasn't trying to make light of dementia or Alzheimer's.
I mean, we all know people affected by it.
The difference is those people can have a great life.
They can be great parents and grandparents and have,
we're not going to give them the nuclear fleet. Well, it w we're gonna,
we're gonna just pretend that it didn't happen and say, congratulations,
here's the largest economy in the world. Here's the nuclear football. I mean,
if Joe Biden needs notes to talk to a reporter,
that's literally trying to love him softballs. How's he going to compete again?
China and Russia and Iran.
Like he can't remember where he is. I mean, so, you know, it's,
it's either insane or it's a cloak and dagger type of thing where they,
you know, they cover Europe.
They pretend it's moderate Joe from Scranton of which he's not. I mean,
he's not blue collar, Joey.
He got his first elected official office in DC when he was in his twenties,
like it's never had a blue collar job, but you know,
he's curated this sort of lie to market himself as this way.
So the radical left, who is actually making all the decisions again,
his platform on his website is Bernie Sanders is right. Yo, his VP is coming,
Oh, Harris,
who's literally left of Bernie Sanders in terms of voting record in the Senate.
Like, do you think Joe,
Biden's going to be able to stand up to them if they're pushing for certain
things. No, but the media can use him as cammo sell to middle America. No, no,
no. It's not going to be that radical. It's not going to be that bad.
But all you have to do is look at his platform. I mean,
$4 trillion tax hike to middle-class America give free healthcare to illegals,
free education, to illegals,
free lawyers for the other ones that will start flooding our country.
Like who's that gonna hurt? Probably not me.
It's going to hurt our lowest income earners, right? Who's that going to hurt?
How about you in a public school that you have the privilege of having to pay
for yet again, right? You don't get free healthcare.
You don't get free education for your kids, certainly not college or anything,
but you have the privilege of paying for illegals to get those benefits because
it creates Democrat voters. I mean, think about how insane that is.
It's not like our systems have all this excess capacity that they can handle it.
I mean, they're already overworked.
Our medical system is already overstressed our education system. Honestly,
our public education system is a disaster. It's 28th in the world spending more,
more money per child than any country in the world. It's still 28. I mean,
there are literally third world countries that are beating us in education and
the teacher's union is really sure they don't want to go back to do in-person,
but they also don't want to do online learning also of their platforms since
you've been gone is they want to support BLM and defund the police.
What does that have to do with educating our children?
These are the radicals that we're going to be in charge.
And if you just look at Joe Biden,
you see the way he has to be carried off the stage after he gives a speech or,
you know, speech, I say speech loosely because you know,
the hardest job in America is being his sign language interpreter because
everyone, no one knows what that is going on.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations, politics.
Instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.